MALE SPEAKER: My
friends, I am so
happy to have our
friends here, Dr. Ari
and Walter-- Walter Link.
Dr. Ari is the
founder Sarvodaya.
Sarvodaya is Sri Lanka's
largest social movement.
Dr. Ari is widely known as
the Gandhi of Sri Lanka.
And in my opinion, Dr. Ari can
be described in just two words,
and the two words
are living saint.
He's a humble
English teacher who
through the sheer
force of his goodness
created the largest social
movement in Sri Lanka involving
15,000 villages,
millions of people,
building thousand of schools,
health centers, libraries,
roads, and village
banks, and so on.
Dr. Ari demonstrates that you
can integrate deep in the work
with transforming every aspect
of human life and the world.
Walter here is a close friend
of Dr. Ari and his family.
He chairs--
DR. WALTER LINK:
Sarvodaya International.
MALE SPEAKER: Sarvodaya
international.
And as Senior Strategy
Advisor and a leadership coach
and associate investment
banker to the organization,
Walter is involved in
the same kind of work.
His work is integration of
personal personal practice
into the broader world.
My friends, please give a warm
welcome to Dr. Ari and Walter.
Let's begin, since
we have a saint here,
let's begin with
some saintly sitting.
I'm going to invite
Dr. Ari to guide us
in a few minutes
of mindful sitting,
and then I'll have
Walter guide us
a few minutes of
relationship practice.
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE: Thank you.
I'm extremely delighted that I'm
able to receive Google again.
Google I remembered because
of this jolly good fellow who
cannot be erased from my
mind from the day I met him.
What we need is human
beings on this planet who
can live all the time
in I call joy of living.
He's one such person.
I'm very humbled to be
back with you and Google,
and I'm looking forward to
greater universal service
on the part of the institution
as well as all of you.
To anything in the
world, mind is supreme.
Therefore, for a
moment, let us try
to develop some
mindfulness by undergoing
a few minutes of meditation.
Please close your
eyes very lightly.
Keep your feet on the ground.
Keep the back erect so that the
nose, the chin, and the chest,
fall in one line.
Keep the right hand
on the left hand.
Just look at your own body.
Head to foot.
Normally, we do not look
at our body with our mind.
Now let us look at
our body and see
how this body is nothing
but getting together
of all elements in nature.
Hardness.
Liquidity.
Air or expandability
or contractability.
And heat.
These are the four elements
that go to make my body.
Similarly, all of us are
made of these four elements
and everything around
us and in the world.
Now we slowly bring our mind
to the tip of the nostrils.
I observe how the breath
enters through the nostrils.
How they escape
through the nostrils.
Sometimes short breaths.
Sometimes long breaths.
Sometimes through one nostril.
Sometimes through both.
For a moment let us observe how
this breath coming in and out
conducts itself.
While trying to concentrate our
mind to breathing in and out,
we feel very relaxed in
body as well as the mind.
How does the mind originate?
We have in this body,
living body, a pair of eyes,
a pair of ears, a
nose, a tongue, a body,
as well as a mind.
But through images that
fall into our eyes,
eye consciousness is created.
Similarly, sounds create
sound consciousness.
Smell creates olfactory,
all smell consciousness.
Tongue creates
taste consciousness.
Body creates feelings.
Mind creates thoughts, memories.
All these six sensations,
senses, create sensations.
Now, while keeping the mind
in breathing in and out,
we try to observe how these
six sensory organs get messages
from outside, creating either
pleasant feelings and thoughts
or creating unpleasant or even
neutral thoughts and feelings.
Observe the six
sensory organs and how
they behave while keeping
the mind always breathing
in and out at the
starting point.
I'm trying to be
mindful to everything
that is happening in this body
mind combination every moment.
While continuing to look
at the breathing in and out
and while continuing to observe
how these sensory organs
conduct themselves with regard
to external stimulation,
see the impermanence
in the eyes,
impermanence in the
objects that the eye sees.
Impermanence in the
eye consciousness.
Impermanence in the ears.
Impermanence of the sound.
Impermanence of the
sound consciousness.
In this manner, the impermanence
of every sensory organ,
including the mind,
the thoughts we get.
In this body or mind, I
cannot discover anything
as a permanent entity.
Everything changes every moment.
I shall attempt to abstain from
holding to anything material
or mental with attachment.
I know that attachment
brings suffering, sorrow.
Now with that observation
of mindfulness of the body
and mind-- body, sensations,
perceptions, relations,
and consciousness.
So these five, they
see as momentary
of momentary existence
and attachment
is not going to
be of any benefit.
The same process takes
place in all of us.
For first I extend loving
kindness to my own body
and mind, then I extend
loving kindness to all of us
present here.
Then let us extend our
loving kindness to all those
who are near and dear to us.
Our parents, our spouses,
our children, our friends,
our colleagues.
May all of them
be well and happy.
May we now extend
the loving kindness
to everybody on this compound.
Everybody in this area,
everybody in our country,
everybody in this world.
From mindfulness of
my own body and mind
and realizing its impermanence
and detaching myself
and reducing my egoism, I
extend my loving kindness
to the entire living
world, entire universe.
With mindfulness we
began, with loving
kindness we expanded our hearts.
It's going to create a critical
mass of spiritual consciousness
in the world without which
there is no peace possible.
Without which we
can't put an end
to enmity, hunger, conflicts.
May I be well and happy.
May all of us be well and happy.
May the entire world
be well and happy.
Thank you.
DR. WALTER LINK: Before
you open your eyes,
please notice the impact
that this practice has
had on your mind and your head.
Not only the thoughts, but
also the energy, the space,
the quality of
experience in your head.
And then notice also the
impact on your feelings.
Internally, without
speaking them,
find a few words that describe
your inner state of feeling.
And then notice also your
belly and the rest of your body
and the sensations
you have there.
Notice that the breath
is flowing in the belly.
Kind of anchor yourself in
this awareness of the breath
in the belly, and then
gently, without rushing,
allow your eyes to
open while remaining
focused in your belly.
Notice that it can be quite
challenging because the eyes
bring in powerful
sensations that
pull us towards the sensation.
And rather let what you
see come to you so that you
see what you see and
hear what you hear
and it enters the space of
you that includes your body.
And you keep noticing the
impact that it has there.
In a moment we will
go into much more
content for the mind, that the
mind hopefully will get curious
about and engaged
with, and we spend
a lot of time in
our head center,
thinking and being inspired.
And it's also good to
keep present in your belly
and in your heart center.
And notice how you're impacted
as we speak in an ongoing way.
Because often we
think that listening
is to pay attention to
the other and especially
to the other's words.
And that's really
important also.
But, really, our
heart and our body
is constantly also
being impacted.
And the more awareness we have
about this impact in ourselves
by the other, the
more freedom of choice
we have how to respond.
And so this is a way how you
can take this ancient Buddhist
practice into really every
moment of your life--
in a business meeting, in
a strategy and innovation
discussion.
We can stay present
to ourselves and see
that there are different
parts of ourselves impacted
and that also the other
person is not only their words
but they might have certain
feelings, a certain presence
that's also really an
important way they communicate.
So it's really a unity.
There's you and me in this
mutual impact that we have.
And when we open
that even further,
then we see that there's
a whole field here,
because we will all
impact each other.
And of course there's the whole
company and the whole world.
And we can listen, use
this mindfulness to really
be aware of what's going on
on these different levels
and keep coming back to that
during our time together.
Just to practice
together and not only
talk about interesting stuff.
So with that, I
pass it on to you.
MALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, my friends.
Dr. Ari, my first
question is for you.
So you started as an
English in college
and you ended up with
a huge social movement.
So my first question is, how?
What was the story behind this?
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE:
While I was a teacher,
my hobby or pastime was to
visit communities, particularly
those that were socially and
economically very depressed
communities.
And then one day in my class,
consisting of teenagers,
I told them the
story of one village.
I said I visited many villages.
The more I visited these
village communities,
the more I feel that there
are things that we as students
also can do without
waiting until we grow up
and take various
kinds of employment.
Then my students suggested, why
don't we organize ourselves,
do it in the next vacation,
go to a village live
with the village people, learn
from them while contributing
to some-- contributing
in some way
or other to satisfy one or
more of their basic needs,
That's how it all
started 56 years ago.
So all these students
and teachers, all of us,
settled down in the village
for a couple of weeks,
and we asked village people
that we will cook together
in one kitchen.
We will eat together.
We will sing together.
We'll meditate together.
We'll dance together
at the same time.
We will share our
labor and whatever
skills we have to build a
well, to build a school,
to build some toilets.
Do some agriculture
work like that.
So we had a timetable.
We are, during two weeks' time,
a physical acheivements of work
was there which anybody
could see, feel, physically.
At the same time, we had
about four hours or more
of meditation, discussion,
learning from one another.
So it began a kind of
educational extension program,
which continued
to other villages,
during other vacations
and weekends.
Then we found ourselves that we
were a big village development
movement.
So we have to organize ourselves
from education to development.
And development
actually was a word
which was meant for animals--
livestock development and all
that.
But I think it was one of
the American presidential--
gave development the connotation
that human beings should
be developed.
In a way, he was right,
because we have degenerated,
most of us, into the
worst of human animals.
Otherwise, these
killings can't go on.
This exploitation can't
go on in the world.
But we give a different
meaning to development.
We said it's an
awakening process.
We have come to this village to
awaken our human personality.
And in our culture, in
the Buddhist teachings,
we have been told that
there are four principles,
very simple to remember, which
could be practised by all of us
at all times to awaken
our personality at work,
when we take a
bath, when we eat.
Whatever we do during the day.
First is loving kindness.
So we practiced this meta
mediation, meditation
on loving kindness,
trying to as much
as possible to make our
ego less and less prominent
and our universal
nature to come up
so that we feel a brotherhood
among all beings, not only
humans.
So there's a spiritual
aspect to it.
And then there's a model aspect.
While we were camping
out in a village,
we were very
particular that there
was no alcohol in that place.
No gambling.
Not even talking unnecessarily.
All this pleasant and
constructive speech,
constructive activity, quality
in association and like that.
So all the work we
did in the village
by way of physical
labor or teaching
or health care or even
doctors coming and helping
to have clinics for the
people without charging--
all of these things became
compassionate action.
So human beings should develop
loving kindness, or meta,
convert that loving kindness
into compassionate action.
So you're seated in
Google, your office,
trying to create something.
If your principle objective
is well-being all of humanity,
then what do you do--
creating a new product,
creating new something for the
company, which in turn is going
to help others is become
compassionate action.
It's not a selfish
kind of action.
And at the end of it I'm
sure, when you discovered
your first [INAUDIBLE]
engineering skill in Google,
you would have felt a
terrific joy of living.
It's human, not
money part of it.
Money is secondary.
We are not going to come
back to get anything from it.
But we feel so happy.
That is called mudita.
That is loving kindness,
compassion, action,
altruistic joy.
And some people turn around
and say, look at those fools,
studying for their examination
and getting a first class pass.
They are going and
wasting their time.
There are some people
who will ridicule you.
Now, this is real
education in my country.
Education at that time
thought this is nonsense.
Trusting that it
interdicted me from my job.
I said, thank you very
much for interdicting me.
I will use that time to do
more work with my students
after school hours,
which I continued to do.
But I said, I have a family.
I have a wife.
I have a couple of children
who [INAUDIBLE] this.
So I'm going to come to
your house for my meals
and see that my salary
is not too stumped.
So I'm got the salary
while I was interdicted.
There was a human
cry in the country
and the bureaucrats
had to give in.
And the president-- the
prime minister called me.
She said, ask the official
who interdicted me either
to repeal the whole thing--
give me everything that I lost--
or for him to go home.
So they asked me what
are the challenges.
From the day one,
it was challenges,
challenges, challenges.
The [INAUDIBLE]
is very necessary.
Whenever you do
something good first,
people will treat you
with indifference.
Then they will start
joking about you,
ridiculing what you are
doing-- this is not education.
Then they'll start
insulting you.
Those days, they
said I'm going out
to villages with boys and
girls to have a nice time.
So insulting you.
Without stopping that they
try to prosecute to you,
to do all kinds of harm
to you and Take your--
make an end to your life
for all of these things.
Then comes the worst.
People begin to respect you.
Now I'm going through
that terrible experience.
I know how weak I am.
I know what weaknesses
I have, but other people
don't believe it.
There are times
when I was smoking.
I was smoking 15 years ago.
Nobody believed I smoked.
[LAUGHTER]
Yet they see me smoking.
Look at Ari!
He doesn't drink.
He doesn't walk.
He talks all that pleasant
language, like that.
So that is a very
dangerous period.
That's why you-- you
have to be careful.
I had to be careful.
All of you have to be careful.
If you do good, the worst comes
last when people respect you.
Then you think, I
know everything.
So therefore,
personality awakening
was our first objective.
Meta, karuna, mudita, uppeka.
Loving kindness.
Compassion, action.
Don't say, I'm doing
a job back at Google.
I'm engaged in compassionate
action in Google.
How nice to say that.
The benefit I get is the
joy of living, creating.
The last thing is we
accept name and blame.
Loss and gain with equanimity.
Those were our first objectives.
Second, third like that.
Afterword, awakening.
These 56 years we have
built up theoretical base
also from practical work.
MALE SPEAKER: I don't know if
anybody of you caught that.
He says 56 years, so Dr. Ari has
been doing this for 56 years.
DR. A.T. ARITARATNE: 56 years.
Before that as a student.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
And he's like--
You're 84 years old?
DR. A.T. ARITARATNE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And he's so vital.
That's one thing that-- in
common between me and Dr. Ari.
Neither one of us
looks a day over 65.
[LAUGHTER]
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Ari,
about equanimity.
There's something else about
equanimity, which fascinates me
about you and to me it
comes-- it appears as courage.
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE: Courage.
MALE SPEAKER: Courage.
So in your case,
I know there was
a gun pointed at
you more than once.
And there was a particular story
I was particularly touched by,
and I know the last time we met,
I asked you whether it was true
and you told me it was true.
And the story was that somebody
tried to assassinate you.
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And
they were going
to bomb a school that
Dr. Ari was visiting.
And Dr. Ari found out
about that and he found out
who the guy was.
And he went to the
guy's house, and he
says, don't bomb the school.
You're just going
to hurt the kids.
So I'm here right now, you're
going to kill me, kill me now.
And the guy decided
not to kill you.
And it could have gone
either way, by the way,
just so you know.
So my question for you, Dr.
Ari, where does this courage
come from, and how is this
courage related to mindfulness?
DR. A.T. ARITARATNE:
You know, first,
try to develop loving
kindness almost to perfection.
I'm not saying I'm perfect,
but supposing you get up
in the morning-- I'm
talking practical things.
As you get up, don't
think of the problem
you have been tackling here.
Just extend your
loving kindness to you
wife, your children, anybody.
Or even if there are
persons you that you
don't like in the neighborhood,
give loving kindness to them.
Then you get ready
and come to office.
On your way back, everybody
you meet-- known or unknown--
sometimes in a very cold
morning, we say good morning.
So we have that
kind of courtesy.
But why not in your
mind tell everybody,
may you be well and happy.
May you be-- Yesterday I was
going on the street with him
or somebody in the
evening day before.
A lady came, young lady,
maybe 30, 40, years.
She looked so pathetic.
Can you give me a dollar?
I was surprised in America
there are people who beg.
So I took out and
gave it to her.
And then somebody else was
with me, he also gave a dollar.
Now, before I gave that, at
that moment we're not talking.
I was extending loving
kindness to everybody.
So when in times of
war, on either side,
there are groups
who are fighting.
But we are announce and say we
are now coming on a peace walk.
When you go on a peace
walk, you go only
looking at the tip of your nose.
So you don't see
anything more than that.
You don't see people with guns.
There are people
with guns there.
You extend loving
kindness to your own body
and mind then proceed.
Extending that loving kindness
to people on either side.
Believe me, they had no
guts to pull the trigger.
So it all comes through
loving kindness.
Then loving kindness-- now
when I was confronted that day
with that criminal,
he was a terror.
Anybody I tell his name, I
wouldn't-- I'll tell his name
without looking, seeing
that there's nobody around.
When I heard this,
of course, I thought
I'm practicing this
loving kindness.
I'll practice it on this
fellow and see what happens.
That way I didn't
know what fear was,
because I was engaged in
something really important.
So I went to him and revealed
why I came and who I was.
He just got up from his
seat and sat down here.
What I realized all my life
is the most cowardish people
are those who take up arms.
They are the first
class cowards.
They fear people
who are fearless.
So during the last
56 years I may
have more than 50 occasions.
Fortunately, up to now,
still when go back this time
I don't know where I will be
because, again, politically
everything is warming up.
And as a neutral
person, everybody's
expecting me to take
this side or that side,
but I won't take any side.
I will take the side of peace
and reconciliation and all
that.
So always when you do
good, you are in danger
because the world is
not that civilized yet
with regard to non-violence.
Therefore, the more you
cultivate this loving kindness,
fear disappears from you.
Actually, I don't
say I'm not afraid.
But there have been occasions
where I should have been afraid
but it was this loving
kindness and nothing else
that filled me.
If-- I believe even
Mahatma Gandhi,
if he had a chance, just
a minute or so before
that fellow shot him, he
would not have got killed.
He had no time even to think.
When he came and killed him.
The victim, I believe, is always
associated with the killer.
If victim does not cooperate,
the killer cannot kill you.
So these things
come to your mind
if you spend hours and
hours in deep meditation.
And so I don't want to
go into details of that
because now I said mindfulness.
Mindfulness leads you to look
at everything as impermanent.
See, I look at my wife,
children, grandchildren
as impermanent.
That doesn't mean that
I do not love them.
I would sacrifice my life to
save them in case of danger.
That's different.
In the back of your mind, you
have to have-- I'm, he or she,
we, all have to have temporary
appearances on this planet.
So then impermanence.
Then once you realize
these two things,
you begin to
separate in your mind
I have good thoughts.
I will never allow
them to escape my mind.
I have some bad thoughts.
I'll get rid of them
as quickly as possible.
I'll bring in new good
thoughts to my mind
I'll never allow a new
bad thought to come in.
That is called right different.
With these three things,
now, I can see in him,
now I can see in
many of my colleagues
when you have these three
things, you're always happy.
Now my-- A lot of
people ask me back home,
how can be such a
responsible man?
Always joking, joking.
Here there are people
killing one another.
You're joking until
it's go and help them.
You know?
How come?
This is the of list of this
four things of happiness
then it become a trait.
You're always happy,
not just momentarily.
The comes the sixth
thing, where you
realize these things
called samadi.
Samadi is right
concentration, where
no thoughts arise in your mind.
It's totally blank After a
blank period of the mind then
you come to the next stage,
pitka, day to day equanimity.
Then your creativity comes.
Then your thoughts come.
So that all these things
have to happen to together.
Therefore, no time
for fear then.
MALE SPEAKER: Speaking about
no good deeds going unpunished,
I have a question for
you, my friend, Walter.
So the question is,
what's a nice guy
doing in a place like this?
I'd like to know
about your involvement
in this organization.
Specifically, I'm
interested to know--
I know that your
organization is trying
to change the
economics of the world,
and I'd like to hear your
views on that as well.
DR. WALTER LINK: As you can
notice, Ari is very convincing,
so he just basically
recruited me.
I was organizing at the
conference at Omega Institute
that I was on the
board on in New York,
and Ari came and he walked
straight to me and he said,
I need you to come
to Sri Lanka and help
us bring this organization
in the 21st century
because we have a
very good thing going,
but we need to understand
how to take the next step,
both in terms of the economic
and the political and social
development environment
and so forth.
And I think what was
relevant in this,
we are-- I think all three
of us-- we are interested not
only to work on a project, even
though a project is important,
but we want to create movements.
And he had read
a book that I had
edited about global leadership,
which was a movement that we
are continuing to try to bring
into the world which really
looks at all the sectors
of society and sees
how can we really
bring about, you
could say a sustainable adjust,
but also very functional
innovation there.
And his organization works
in all sectors of society.
So it really
requires a rethinking
of all these different
things, and I myself
came from running a
big, traditional company
and then moved on to
transforming business
by bringing together many people
who owned and ran companies
to show there is really a
different way and it works.
It's not some kind of ideal.
Because I think
that's really what
makes a real, concrete movement.
It's not just to have an
aspiration that is inspiring
but then people
look at their life
and the stretch seems
too big and there's
no guidance about how to move
from where they are to actually
implementing the changes
that are necessary to reach
that inspirational place.
And so that's where we
started to deep dialogue
and deep collaborations
in bringing
about these movements, not
only in Sri Lanka but also
internationally.
MALE SPEAKER: Dr. Ari, I
have a question for you.
There are so many things
about you that inspire me
and one of those many things
is that what you do actually
works.
And so I compare what you
do to international aid,
when rich countries
keep the poor countries
and the money just
disappear to corruption,
but you don't do that.
You start doing nothing.
You're just a
schoolteacher, and what
you did was inspire people to
give the gift of labor and love
to each other and in
doing so it created
the whole massive movement,
like 15,000 bridges, millions
of dollars, schools, and
so forth, have been built.
And so my question
for you is, first,
how, what can people learn
from this thing that you did,
that inspired people to be
able to give to each other?
And also, I'm interested to
know about grassroot democracy,
and I know you've done
some thinking somewhat
in that field, and I want to
know what's the current state
and what can we learn
from that as well?
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE:
You may remember
I started by talking about
individual personality
reasoning.
Next comes family
then the community
then groups and
nations and the world.
So awakening is something that
could be implemented, starting
from the individual
to the world level.
But, unfortunately, most of
the modern economic, social,
and political theories are
based on not naturalistical kind
of approach, not for
the well being of all.
Well being of the majority.
That Mahatma Gandhi
coined word sarvodaya,
which we adopted from India.
Because our language
also rooted in Sanskrit,
So this word was
similar to our language.
So we adopted the word
sarvodaya from Mahatma Gandhi.
So this concept
of working for all
is something that Buddhists try
to always have. [INAUDIBLE].
May all beings be
well and happy.
Now if I-- if a mosquito
lights on my hand,
if I kill the mosquito, my
mother will turn to me and say,
why did you kill that mosquito?
That mosquito also
has a right to live.
Where else can
this mosquito live?
You should have
chased him out or not
allowed mosquitoes to breed.
So respect for life is
the eye of our culture.
That life is the art the
heart of every living being.
So we had to think of
development models, which
take this kind of basic
truths into consideration.
So truth, nonviolence,
and self-reliance,
were the three principles
on which we started.
We told our communities,
you are poor.
Governments if they
have no money therefore
they can't give you a
water service scheme.
Wells or irrigation
tanks or anything.
Why do we did?
In the modern economies you
talk of land, labor, capital,
and entrepreneurship,
like what you
were taught in the universities.
But in our ancient culture
it's not land, it's nature.
It's not labor, it's
human personality.
It's not money, it's not
capital, it's social wealth.
It's not entrepreneurship
only, it is science and wisdom.
Ancient culture.
Let us bring these five
factors of progress
together and see what happens.
Thousands of people to join to
cut the road to the village.
Dig wells.
From nature itself
collect material
and put up houses, not big,
concrete, modern houses,
but livable houses with plenty
of yard and sunlight and all
that.
So that kind of
creativity, they never
thought of after they
became independent in 1948
they thought of imitating
of the western world who
had a lot of money from
exploitation, from conquests.
We didn't have that
kind of capital.
So we had to have
our own process
and we call it an
awakening process,
and then of course the problem
we have is all these things
are imitated by governments and
others with limited objectives.
Political or
profitable objectives.
But not for the [INAUDIBLE]
being of humanity
but now I think there are
many institutions from around
the world come and
spend time with us
from universities, scholars,
World Bank, and IMF
and all these organizations
come, and I am really careful.
We have several thousand
working in the moment.
full time and many
more [INAUDIBLE].
I told them to be
very, very careful
of experts and consultants.
You know that joke
about consultants?
A consultant went to the village
and asked a village woman,
your hen lays eggs every day?
Any problem?
No problem.
Then this expert was
very disappointed
because there was nobody
to get advice from him.
When he was getting
into the car,
the woman ran to the expert
and said, yes, sir, I
have a problem.
Can you tell me
how to distinguish
between a male chick
and a female chick.
He said, you have to
ask the chicken expert.
I am only some other expert.
So experts come and go.
I have been an
expert myself for one
and a half am months in Uganda.
I was paid so much
I felt sick of it.
I got a another one recommended
to do my job and I came home.
I didn't know what to
with all that money.
[INAUDIBLE] and there's
a nice meditation center.
All of you can
come and meditate.
MALE SPEAKER: I have one last
question for both of you, which
is how are you going to turn
this into a global movement
and how do we help you do that?
DR. A.T. ARIYARATNE: I think
this world needs three things
to happen.
If we are to eliminate
conflict as well as hunger
and other causes for
this present situation,
one is, democratize the
economic and social life
by decentralized planning
and organization, what
we call ground surround.
Have governments of communities.
Imagine the planet with
communities of 100 families,
maybe 200 families, maybe
a little less, maybe
a little more, having maximum
possible freedom to decide
what they want to do with least
interference from the top.
That is one.
Total devolution or
decentralization of power.
Second thing is, unless there is
a spiritual foundation on which
these people unite,
it won't work.
[INAUDIBLE]
Again, demand
somebody from the top
to send the army or the police
to say settle our dispute.
This building.
So second thing is a
spiritual awakening.
Third thing is, while you
have that critical mass
of spiritual consciousness,
keeping the people together,
you need the most modern
communication technology
going to every village, every
community, in the planet.
To prepare for this we have
a section called fusion,
because we really don't know
how to handle IT and all that.
What I said what they were
doing me a good thing.
We can reach more and more
and more and more people.
And knowledge.
So start training people in
this so at least a couple
of people in our villages
are competent to handle
computers, the
internet, like that.
Now that, we need a
lot of help from you.
That is, if you can get
our 15,000 village network,
which is now experimenting with
total decentralized banking.
There are so many areas we
need help in technology.
We are a very poor organization.
We don't have a tax.
For his donation he
gave some time ago,
they did lot of work
including a good publication.
I don't agree with the
theme of the publication.
It happened to be
about a person.
That is myself,
which I don't like.
So many have helped
us in different ways.
Now he is giving us first class,
western, scientific knowledge
also combined with
eastern spirituality
without spending a
cent on our part.
So that way those who
have knowledge, money,
and other expertise
should share it with us,
we will share with you.
We also have a lot of expertise
derived from ancient living
culture normal in our village.
SPEAKER: One minute.
Any last words from you?
DR. WALTER LINK: Yes.
So I think you
spoke about courage.
I think one of the most
important things that everybody
could do is to have the
courage to really listen
to their deepest inspiration.
I think we are very
discouraged in doing that.
And then to really look at
every institution of our society
and really look and see like how
can that really fully represent
our humanity and the
sustainability that we want,
and what can we
learn from Sarvodava?
We are working, for example,
on a big movement outreach
to reinvent democracy
which, also in this country
and in many countries around
the world, as we know,
get stale and formal
and loses the alive,
dialogic, interchange where
we really get together
to co-create the
understanding of how
we want to live together.
So I think that's a
very interesting project
that we could talk more about.
Secondly, fact is
that businesses
now impact society in
such a massive way,
that we really need to think
about how to create companies
that really represent
this deepest inspiration,
and so what we're
doing, for example, is
we took a non profitable
nonprofit that
was doing microfinance and
gave very good social service,
but wasn't really a model
for reinventing the economy
because it was just another
nice social institution.
We are transforming that into
a fully regulated bank that
presently is growing
at 100% every year
and that requires really a
very big cultural change also
in the organization where
people that we're used to just--
be good, also had to integrate
being good as being really
effective, and I think
this is also what we need.
There is a good
challenge in business
to integrate really
this deep humanity
with doing it in
a way that works.
And I think, for example,
when we look at innovation.
Innovation isn't just doing
something new and different.
It's doing something that really
serves the world, only then
does it really deserve
the word innovation.
And all of that will
only happen [INAUDIBLE]
aspect that I think
we can learn here.
Find a way for ourselves, how
we really develop our potential.
Because it's not some kind
of theory, this potential,
it's a moment to
moment opportunity
to be more and
more, step by step.
Deeper in our hearts,
deeper in our clarity.
Deeper in a responsibility
of interacting,
and there are wonderful,
ancient methodology
and modern, contemporary
methodologies
that help us to do that.
And we really need to
start bringing them
into our day-to-day life
and see that with them we
get empowered to
really be democratic.
Because we cannot be
democratic if we're stuck
in our judgmental minds and
cannot really feel the value
of another person
or their opinion.
We cannot really reinvent a
company if we can't access this
creativity and cooperation
that brings about new things,
and so I think the inner needs
to be understood as being
inseparable from the outer.
It's only in modernity
that we separate
private life and
professional life.
Inner life and outer
life, they live
business and social service.
Spirituality and this.
It's all one life, and
when we live that life
in a unified way, then
it also brings to us
a unified satisfaction
and effectiveness
of impact in the world.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you, my friends.
And with that, Dr.
Ari and Walter.
Thank you.